c'est ta station au revoir, qu'est-ce que
je fais ici en fait je ne vais pas te le
dire ne t'inquiète pas tu vas le
comprendre la dernière fois que je l'ai vu, il
se dirigeait vers Epps et puis il
disparaît, quelque chose de grave lui est arrivé
sachez ce qui lui est arrivé si vous êtes
venu chercher des réponses, demandez-moi ce que vous ne
savez pas, c'est quoi les développeurs, c'est le seul
principe que vous devez comprendre, rien
n'arrive jamais sans raison, tout
a été déterminé par quelque chose avant, ce
sont des fanatiques,
nous avons besoin du policier.  tu veux les
éliminer c'est impossible tu savais que j'allais
venir ici
le sentiment que tu participais à la
vie n'était qu'une illusion la vie est
juste quelque chose que nous surveillons par faute
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur de tout ce
que vous
[Applaudissements]